[Music]
there's two types of potatoes starchy
and waxy for mashed potatoes you want a
starchy potato a potato with higher
starch and low moisture will yield a
fluffier inside we're using yukon gold
potatoes they're actually somewhere in
between a starchy and a waxy potato
they're harder to over mash and have a
foolproof creamy texture we're going to
peel the potatoes before boiling some
people like to leave the skin on their
mashed potatoes which creates a little
bit more texture but for really creamy
silky smooth mashed potatoes with a
uniform texture it's going to work a lot
better with the skin off
quick tip to keep your potatoes from
discoloring and oxidizing as they sit
out place them in a bowl of cold water
while you work
after you've peeled your potatoes cut
them into one inch cubes this way
they're going to cook more quickly and
evenly
add your potatoes to a pot of cold water
and add a very generous pinch of salt
this is going to help build the layers
of flavor as the potatoes cook which
means you'll need less salt down the
line
now we're going to bring the potatoes to
a soft boil over high heat
once you've reached a soft boil reduce
the heat to low and simmer for about 12
minutes you'll know your potatoes are
ready for mashing when they're fork
tender go ahead and remove the pot from
the heat and drain the potatoes through
a colander at this point you're actually
going to place the potatoes back in the
pot over medium-high heat and stir them
around for 2-3 minutes that's just going
to release any excess moisture at the
end of this the potatoes should be super
dry
when it comes to mashed potatoes most
people use a potato masher or even a
fork some people use a potato ricer for
a more uniform texture which we're also
really big fans of if you don't have any
of those tools and want to get a similar
result you can use a fine mesh sieve
place the boiled potatoes in the sieve
and use a spatula to gently push them
down i'm not gonna lie this definitely
takes more muscle and is more time
consuming but the potatoes are going to
be so silky smooth and beautiful it's
really worth the effort whatever you do
do not use a food processor or a hand
mixer this is going to overwork the
potatoes creating a gummy like paste and
let's be real no one wants that now it
wouldn't be mashed potatoes without
adding some butter you want to use
unsalted butter because it allows you to
control the amount of salt in your
mashed potatoes we made so many
variations of mashed potatoes and taste
tested all of them we tried cold butter
milk melted butter sour cream cream
cheese heavy cream and after all that we
decided to stick with melted butter and
heavy cream while some people do like
sour cream and cream cheese we found
that the flavor really stood out and
took away from that uniform consistency
and texture that we were looking for
quick tip you always want to add your
butter before adding any cream or milk
this is going to ensure that the texture
of the potato remains firm before being
softened by all that cream if you add
your butter and your cream all at once
it's going to create this really soupy
texture whereas if you go gradually
it'll be nice and smooth and creamy so
remember how we talked about building
flavors this is another time where
you're going to season it with salt add
your heavy cream to a small saucepan
over medium-high heat this is also the
moment when you can enhance the flavor
of your mashed potatoes we're going to
add some rosemary sprigs and garlic but
you can get creative with other herbs
and ingredients as well bring the heavy
cream mixture to a simmer once it's
simmering for a few minutes and that
cream is getting really infused with
flavor you're going to strain out the
garlic and the rosemary through a sieve
and then add just the cream to the
potatoes little by little until they're
fully incorporated
remember if you add all the heavy cream
at once it's just gonna become a soupy
mess
as you fold the heavy cream into the
mashed potatoes you're gonna see this
really smooth textures start to come
together
i mean it's so beautiful
it's that easy your potatoes are finally
ready to serve
so because it's tasty we're going to top
it with more butter
we're also going to add some freshly
ground black pepper some chives
you can really experiment with your
toppings but this is a pretty classic
preparation
even though we're going to be breaking
it down to its pieces we still want to
be cognizant of how big our bird is so
typically they say about a pound per
person
the fda no longer recommends washing
your bird because it can spread and
contaminate the rest of your kitchen so
we're just going to take it out of the
packaging pat it down with paper towels
and get moving my first time breaking on
a bird a lot of this is just making
these exploratory cuts so you can see
what you're doing so just be slow take
your time shouldn't be a ton of cutting
through bone
we're gonna take out the neck and the
innards we're also gonna super quickly
cut off the wingtips those would just
char roasting with the rest of the stuff
so we're going to use those for our
stock and we're going to turn our bird
over first thing we want to do is
release the oysters and the oysters are
this really great chunk of meat on the
back of the bird and they are attached
to the thighs here are wings those are
our oysters and our legs and thighs
so we're going to do a cut down the
backbone just to release the skin and
make a little cross you can kind of feel
them right here and just cut above them
we're just going to use the tip of your
knife and kind of scrape around and
release that oyster it's kind of like a
half circle if you will and if you leave
some meat on the bone that's totally
fine you just want to get as much as you
can and once you get it released to this
point you're going to turn the turkey
over
now we're going to release the legs
here our wings up here and our breast
first off you're just going to release
the skin with your knife just one smooth
motion and that's just so that we can
see what we're doing now so you're going
to use your fingers being careful always
keep your fingers away from your knife
we're going to first start by releasing
some of the meat from the bottom of the
carcass right where my hand is at this
point we're just going to pop out the
joint so it's kind of crazy you kind of
like put your hand underneath the thigh
with your other hand move the rest of
the carcass off to one side use your
fingers to pop the joint out
you'll feel some pressure and then all
of a sudden it'll pop once we release
the thighs and the legs we're just going
to leave them here they're just acting
as a stabilizer and we're going to move
up to the breast and remove that so with
the breastbone we're going to cut down
the middle again a little exploratory
cut then you can use your fingertips to
feel where the edge of the breastbone is
and just do nice long smooth cuts
i like to kind of release the smaller
thinner part of the breast and kind of
fold it up as i go and fold it to the
side so i can really see where i'm going
and scrape down the breastbone as best i
can to release all the meat
just work slow and steady your main goal
is to get as much meat off as you can
you can see there's some tendons up here
near the shoulder and we're just looking
for that shoulder joint going to use the
tip of my knife and scrape off any meat
so that i can see a little bit better
cut through any tendons and then the
nice thing about the shoulder joint is
it's quite large once you get to that
point you can kind of see right where it
is and use the tip of your knife to
expose it if you're hitting the right
place it shouldn't be hard on your knife
now we have our breast and our wing
removed we're going to put that off to
the side so we can get the next breast
off so do the same thing we're going to
go on the other side of the breastbone
and release the rest of the breast as we
go
and
voila so we started removing the legs
and the thighs but now we're going to
finish that process
i'm just going to kind of pull the
carcass away from the thigh and just
start releasing the tendons and the skin
and the meat away from the carcass
the one thing that we want to be aware
of here is we want to take that oyster
with us
here's the thigh here's the leg and then
the oyster is in that top right
same to deal with the other one so kind
of pull the carcass away release the
meat and skin where you can taking that
oyster with you
and we're off
[Music]
so i'm going to use the carcass now
i'm going to take the tips with me as
well and the turkey neck and we're going
to roast those off with some vegetables
and make a really good stock do not
throw this stuff away please make the
stock it's going to make your gravy
taste insane
i'm just going to clean down a little
bit i'm going to fresh board clean off
my knife get some fresh gloves always
working with a clean environment and
always being really organized so we got
these big regions off the bird but now
we're going to break these off into
their grocery pieces if you will so we
have the thing and the leg we want to
separate those two so the easiest way is
to turn them over because you don't have
that skin inhibiting where you can see
you have this fat line in between and
it's kind of this weird natural line
that's telling you where to cut which is
great so we're going to cut right along
that fat line to expose the skin again
we're always looking for the joint you
can find the joint and you can use the
little tip of your knife to kind of
separate a little bit and then just cut
right through it again if this is really
hard then you're probably in the wrong
place so just kind of move your knife
around a few times until you get a
really nice smooth cut all right so here
is our breast and our wing the nice
thing about this too is that now you
know where all the bones are so it's
going to make it much easier when you're
carving later if you've ever carved a
whole bird and you're just guessing your
way through it this is going to make it
so much easier later on when you're
portioning out the different pieces
because of the way that we cut off the
breast it's basically boneless so all we
really need to do is cut off the
shoulder bit so don't overthink this you
can cut a good amount of the breast beat
off and have it go with the wing because
it's like a little bit of an extra treat
for whoever gets the wing part as well
as it just makes your life easier one
thing that we want to be aware of too is
that all the pieces are relatively close
in size
[Music]
we'll follow that up with the other
breast and the other thigh
and then we are good to go so we're
going to clean down real quickly again i
just want to make sure that i'm being as
clean as possible
really hot soapy water get all the bits
really do a good job and then follow up
with a spray sanitizer or antibacterial
spray
so into our brine so o'brien really just
consists of salt and sugar i'm not a big
believer in a wet brine dry brine for
life salt and sugar are desiccants and
they are going to draw out moisture but
once they dry out that moisture it then
re-seeps back into the meat so you get a
really flavorful really juicy meat when
it's all said and done so i'm going to
start with salt
brown sugar so it's going to give us a
little bit of a molassy flavor
molasses as corrected molasses flavor
oh fine it gives us a little molasses
flavor and then i'm going to use some
cracked black pepper look at this this
is freshly cracked nice big chunks not
only that like a weird powder stuff that
comes pre-done so much more aromatic and
flavorful i'm going to use a little bit
of garlic granule so this is kind of in
between a powder and the dried like
chips that you can get the nice thing
about the garlic granules is that they
have a ton of flavor but they
incorporate really really well so stir
those all together something about a
spice mix isn't it pretty put that off
to the side and we're going to bring
back our turkey the cool thing about
breaking the turkey down in its pieces
is that we're really able to season all
sides of the meat which is another great
reason to be breaking your meat down
ahead of time so some birds will have a
few feathers left in don't freak out
just pull them out you have tweezers
that can be helpful but they should be
pretty big so if you don't get all of
them it's fine they'll kind of burn off
when roasting but if there's any huge
ones you want to get those out and then
we're going to season all sides of the
bird just make sure i'm kind of patting
it down getting all sides and all the
skin
really well coated in the brine we're
doing this day ahead so we're going to
actually leave these in the fridge
uncovered overnight that's going to
really draw the moisture out of the skin
so we're going to have super super
crispy great skin when it's all said and
done
for making the stock because we want to
do the gravy we want to mimic those
great roasty toasty dripping bits that
you would get from roasting your turkey
so i'm going to throw the turkey carcass
the wingtips and the neck on a baking
sheet i'm going to put on celery onions
i'm going to quarter those leave the
skin on and then also some carrots as
well
lightly season everything because all
these flavors will be concentrated i
don't want to over salt this and a
little bit of oil again for lubrication
throw that in a super hot oven for about
30 minutes or so just to get a little
bit of that my yard reaction from all
the meat as well as caramelize the sugar
in the vegetables and then i'm going to
take everything that was on this tray
and put it into a big pot cover it with
water so i'm going to pour off all the
extra fat and i'm going to put some
water on this hot baking tray and scrape
all of those brown bits look at all of
the flavor that's on here that's all
that onion sugar and the drippings from
the carcass basically like deglazing the
baking tray
[Music]
so i have the fat in one and the liquids
in the other
these drippings will be saved for the
gravy
[Music]
so with the carcass i'm gonna cover this
up with water all the way and then
simmer this guy for about two and a half
three hours or so and that's gonna give
you the most delicious stock you've ever
tasted it's gonna be amazing
so when you're making a gravy the first
step is making a roux and a roux is
equal parts flour and fat so we're going
to use our fat drippings from roasting
the carcass and then we're going to add
equal parts flour and we're going to
just toast this off for a little bit so
we want to cook the flour a little bit
before we add too much liquid
and that's to do two things one it's
going to help beat out any lumps and two
it's going to help cook out the flour
flavor and we're going to gradually add
liquid to this because if you add too
much liquid at once it's going to be
really really hard to beat out those
lumps just the best way to ensure that
you're going to have a really smooth
gravy in the end so i'm going to take my
time here adding a little bit of liquid
as we go do have to babysit it quite a
bit and again we're going to use all of
the drippings from when we were
deglazing the pan earlier so i'm going
to use a strainer just to be extra safe
because there were you know some of the
onion and other skin and stuff remaining
on the pan from the drippings add the
rest of that in all the fat and all of
the drippings are incorporated but it's
still pretty thick flour it will start
to thicken once it gets to a boil see
that's why you want to keep the heat
pretty high because if you're on too low
of a heat all this time you'll be afraid
to add too much liquid because it won't
thicken up now we're going to use the
stock that we made to finish off this
gravy and thin it out a little bit you
could also use water which is going to
really not be a ton of flavor you could
do store bought if you've decided not to
make the stock but trust me the stock
that we made earlier is going to make a
big big difference so once you get to a
good place and you feel like it's a good
thinness while we use a little bit of
salt just to kind of enhance the flavor
of the meat and the vegetables before we
haven't seasoned it at all so you want
to make sure that you taste it and
you're going to have to add a
significant amount of seasoning right
now because again we haven't really
added much seasoning up until this point
and again just keep tasting and
seasoning until it's just right all
right so i'm happy with this we're gonna
put it off to the side to cool and then
that's done so all you need to do on the
day of is just reheat that in a pan and
it's done
we're gonna preheat our oven to 425 just
go ahead and put a little bit of oil on
it and that will help with even browning
and we're gonna leave it in there for
about 30 minutes that's going to get us
instant heat instant color and really
dry out that skin right away and then
once it's been in for about 30 minutes
we're going to lower it down to 400.
switch the positions of the pans and
rotate them as well just if you have any
hot spots in your oven this will just
help with that and then continue
roasting until the instant read
thermometer inserted into the thickest
part of the breast registers 160. so
this is about like 30 minutes and for
the thighs we want to take it out around
170. so if any pieces are already done
and others need a little bit more time
you can just pull those out ahead of
time so they don't ever cook
once our turkey's done take it out of
the oven cover it with foil let it sit
for about five to ten minutes because
these are smaller pieces they don't need
to rest as long as a whole birds they'll
cool down a lot faster
and then we'll carve them
so now that our meat has cooled a little
bit it's a little bit easier to handle
we're going to carve it for the table
the thigh again it's easier to see on
the other side you can see where that
bone is and we're going to cut off the
meat in large chunks again just cutting
off the bone as best you can cut off the
top like all that meat around the bone
it's the less pretty stuff but it's
still delicious so we're gonna put that
in the bottom of the platter and the way
that i'm cutting this is i'm making sure
that every bite has a little bit of skin
next up we're gonna separate the wing
and the easiest way to do this is just
put it on its side cut down the middle
and then you can even just kind of like
tear it apart you can see you expose
that joint cut through it and good to go
and then all of that meat that we put on
there all that white meat from the
breast is on there as well so that's a
good piece the leg it's perfect as it's
just put it on the platter and then
another thigh same deal look how juicy
it is it's amazing
then for the breast again i'm going to
cut down
the skin on a diagonal and making sure
that everyone's getting a little bit of
skin because you have done all these
pieces you can take your time making all
these cuts really nice and making your
platter really great because you haven't
had to completely carve out an entire
bird so it should be a lot easier and
you have a little bit more time for that
presentation so i like to put the
dark meat on the side again all of those
smaller cuts that were a little bit
uglier go on the bottom and then you
just lay those nice breast pieces on top
the really impressive cuts
and then i like to just spruce it up
with a little bit of green
this is how it would come to the table
normally people don't even know that you
didn't cook it on the carcass if you
want to tell people that you did that's
fine but i think we should evangelize
this method we made gravy from it we
made stock from the whole things you
learned how to break down a bird as well
it's so much cheaper to be buying whole
chickens whole turkeys hold ducks you
name it and now that you know how to
break it down it's the same method for
all birds i just can't understand why
you wouldn't do it this way honestly
going forward this is the only way i'm
doing my turkey from now on sometimes
traditions just need to be upgraded you
know and like updated enjoy have a great
holiday season guys
[Music]
my aunt is the only person in our family
that still bakes sweets she's the only
person that's kind of carried this
recipe over from my grandmother and just
kind of passed down those southern roots
so the way that you will know your
potatoes are done you just kind of give
it a little poke for a little stab
that's how you know that it's ready i
grew up in atlanta and my parents are
from this town in alabama called
monroeville
so thanksgiving christmas like whatever
holiday you can think of we would drive
down for my grandma i remember like she
would just always have all this food and
she didn't have a lot of money and all
that but you could guarantee
that there was going to be a spread
everything that you ever wanted she knew
all your favorites and that was her way
of showing love and i feel like that is
what
southern cooking is all about it's just
a way to show love and and give back to
your family in a different kind of way
i'll say this i'm always looking forward
to this pie for thanksgiving and
christmas i might even volunteer to make
the sweet potato pie this year nobody's
probably gonna let me do it though or
they'll let me do like one and then
she'll do all of them
anybody makes anything good like if you
know something's really good at
thanksgiving it just goes so if you
don't get to that pie before it's gone
forget about it yeah you better get it
when you can
and people i mean we do shares very much
about community but people like what
they like
we all know each other's favorites so
yeah once it's gone
that's it this is just one of my
all-time favorites it's the thing i can
eat i mean i can eat a whole pie by
myself
so my aunt surprised me by letting me
know that she uses lemon extract in
the sweet potato pie when she said it i
was like is she making a mistake but
it's been perfect for years so i'm sure
she knows what she's talking about
here's the thing i don't think anyone
can cook sweet potato pie like anybody
in my family nobody does it quite like
we do but hey to all the aunties and
grandmas and people out there like you
guys are amazing and i just think we're
all partial to our
family's cooking thanksgiving for us is
just like the best time of the year
probably my favorite holiday just
because it's so much about family and
food and eating and just having a good
time
it tastes so good
my aunt's gonna be super proud
oh yes
[Music]
you